いやー
家の外壁がきたなぁ今日は肇社長ですあのー
家の外壁飽きたんですよほんと賃貸なんですけどもほぼ1点やな感じの言いますんで
ますで外壁がこんな感じですはいすごくグリーン町でめちゃくちゃ綺麗でオサレなん
ですけども
佐々木にことをさん4年住んでるんでちょっと飽きてきちゃったかといっても祖父に
賃貸です
大谷さんは何でもしていいよって言ってもらっているものの花弁の色の塗り替えとか
改造をはさせないダメだ
別の遮断でなんとかいや外壁で帰れないかなと思ったところダンボール大量に買ってき
ました今日の動画は2軒の外壁を全部ダンボールでせみようという動画でございます
[音楽]
相当きついと思いますよく考えると家で下院であるためのダンボールも相当な量が入る
んですよ第が安心してください
バーンを期して愛用のガムテープ大量の段ボールしっかりと準備させていただきました
ちょっと炎天下で徳松んですけどもなんとかしていうのが維持をすべてダンボールにし
て家に来る人たちをびっくりさせて宮田思いますが見た目変わる点者も上がるんだよな
いい感じこの立つもなんかも冷たく過ごせるんじゃないかなと思いまして立っすぐダン
ボール貼り付け作業
行ってきますえっ
はい定義でまずはダウンボールを風に伸ばして
オフ率の高さと一緒になるくらい長くしますそれが一番大変です
こーゆーすけあをつなぐしていきたいですねランボールの切れ目が縁の切れ目と言い
ますから
ん
ban
ええええええ
はい結構の長さになったので一回した顔してみます
はいこんな感じでラモードと思ったいうただして言ってまずは外壁をしっかり乱暴に
することから始めていきたいとおもいます
ちょっと今日から強いなその通りだったガムテープでダンボールをつけてもいい
[音楽]
メンタルをれて翌日です稼ぐツールとダンボール長すぎると思いしいろいろ扱って
バギーてが詰んでますけれども食べの下の部分を何ボールピザ下手張ってまず自分を
重ねていこうと思います
って言っ
あっ
[音楽]
てもいい
お前マジでお前さぁ将来自分がやばい今都営
あった
てください安全面とか爪社長の歯のマークです
[音楽]
はい1時間いたしましたドリームレスすんなと言いますとシッターは結構も幹線近い
ですよねしたもバッチリ合ってて結構もういいんじゃないかってくればたれてまたをれ
てますねこうだったの根張りが重いな
1時間で1回できたから2時間3時間
終了ですカベ窒化余裕だったらカーーーンにょ
ちょっと足場も強くなってくるんでちょっと気をつけながら作業いきたいとおもいます
とかたあああ
ん
うわっおバカなか分からない何変な見放せがほらない
ねーなーんなまずなあーか次会ったらまずしばらく
[音楽]
まん
音が入ったん
[音楽]
うそれがたいやーいいんじゃないかなぁ
は存在ですかねぇ
あとは上だけだねもうそこダメ
全然実演そう
に帰りてやる2時間な経過しました
レンズをご覧下さいませ1回や保護できて肉塊も結構もう
肌ハイツ雨だけでこっからが問題なんだよなぁ上らへんが本当に難易度高いと思われ
ますして卒メンももうちょっと張りたいんですよねちょっと頑張っていきます
[音楽]
ん
あっ
というわけでこれぐらいの大きな規模のダンボール作業になるとその分様をしながら
しっかり開く悪いを決めてやって言ってるんでちょっと各部署の紹介していきたいと
おもいます
どうぞこちらが ap 1回の方で働くゴリラー制作部の皆さんです今日はよろしくお
願いします
本日けど地盤を固めるタイプでねっ
おかないと走らないねぇ
失敗ますどうぞ
5クラフト製作部となっておりますクラフトでタグれた
はいそうですよろしくお願いしますはい離しなさいこういうダンボールを接続して外の
人に渡すという作業をしております
魚魚てっ
してボクらそれぞれの仕事にんですはいですよろしくお願いしますお願いします上から
段ボールを投げて私にパッするブースターを打っておりねそうですね
やり込みうれしいぜっ
そして僕は特集管轄迷彩グループです基本的にいろんな作業マルチやっていくんです
けどまあ全体がまとめ役と指示出したかもやらせていただいております
お願いします
[音楽]
エイ
なんということでしょう
あんなに素敵なパステルカラーのグリーンだった理由の界壁はあっという間に物々しい
ダンボールの壁に変身してしまったのです
6人で力を合わせダンボールを壁に貼り付け張り水貼り付けまくり
独特な雰囲気を放つ段ボールハウスが完成したのです
このお家の特徴は雨に濡れればワンパン
一瞬でぐしゃぐしゃになる何とも履かない建物なのです
果たして
意味があるのでしょうかんんん
me
寝るだけのみなさんおつかれさまでしたじゃあ次でだいたい4時間じゃない姉が全部
ダンボールに
おおつかれさまでしたそれではやってみて
花言葉をつけましたねーどうでした
[音楽]
いうものですねこれどうでした達成感が凄い難波清覧本当にまず6人がリピや本気でも
no 1ぺーに作用して付でよかったんですね一人だったら4かける5分で24時間
から警官になりますねこの後このうちにくるメンバーたちは早速で驚かして行きたいと
思います闇のよく頑張ったことに
ございました俺たち
シールこらー
ん
[音楽]
えっ
米なにこれっ4階なにこれ
どういうことを
すごい
ん
頑張ったなぁ
[音楽]
padi
あれ
4 aa